president biden says
the war is now over i have ended the war
in afghanistan no he hasn't he's pulled
the american troops out he's betrayed
those troops that fought there for 20
years he's betrayed his own countrymen
who are now at greater threat from
terrorism than before 911 and he's
betrayed the people of afghanistan
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people we are so pleased to say that our
brilliant guest today is a retired
british army officer who served in
afghanistan colonel richard kemp welcome
to trigonometry it's my pleasure to be
with you thank you for having me it's a
great pleasure to have you on the show
we're so delighted you could join us
today we wanted obviously to talk about
afghanistan but before we get into that
tell everybody a little bit about your
your personal story your history how are
you where you are what has been your
journey through life and obviously
please do touch on your experiences in
afghanistan as well
i went to i was born in essex and i went
to school in a town called colchester
which france has just admitted to me
that he also went to university so it's
a small world um
i i never really grew up
um and all the time at school i loved
playing soldiers
and i just wanted to be a soldier so i
left school one day joined the army the
next i was atrocious i was the worst
pupil at my school it was called kosher
or grammar school fantastic school and
still is today
but
i was the biggest failure they ever had
so it was for me it was either prison or
the army so i went into the army
and i stayed there for 30 years
um i couldn't really get used to it so i
left after 30 years and
i i went into a bit of a time as a
corporate security director in london
and after that in around about 2012 i
became self-employed and i now
write i um do commentary on security
defense etc
and uh and i do some consultancy work
it's a bit of public speaking and we met
precisely because you were doing tv we
were back in the green room and we had a
little chat and i was just so impressed
with how unfiltered and direct you are
about the situation that was being
discussed at the time which was
afghanistan i think the dust is settling
a little bit now we can have a more
measured conversation about it but give
us your overall thoughts on on you know
it's been 20 years were we right to go
in did we do things right when we were
there were we right to leave uh what was
your impression of the things that have
happened i think we were absolutely
right to go and we had no choice of them
to go into afghanistan in 2003
which is or peggy poden in 2001 2002
when we went in there i mentioned 2003
because that was when i was there for
the first time but uh we were right to
do it we you know we just had the
biggest terrorist attack in the history
of the world in which more britons were
killed and had been killed in any other
terrorist attack anywhere um there were
more casualties sustained on 911 than
had been sustained
um
in in pearl harbor when the japanese
attacked america that led to the second
world war and a nuclear bombing of japan
so um
you know it wasn't a small event it was
something that had to be avenged and had
to be
the repeat of which had to be prevented
so we needed to go in i think you could
certainly question i do what happened
after that after we got rid of the
taliban and al-qaeda out of afghanistan
and whether it was necessary to stay
there 20 years but given that we had
done that
i think it was a real disaster to leave
when we did
for very many reasons but i think we
left
too short notice we left without the
conditions being set or any restrictions
being placed on the taliban and we left
um without giving the chance to the uh
the afghan governments and the afghan
security forces to
um to prepare for a totally new
situation that they were now facing and
we did so at the height of the taliban
fighting season when they were in their
most active period so that explains i
think to a very large extent why it all
went wrong and the consequences we
haven't even begin
to understand yet
and you say we haven't begun to
understand the consequences what do you
think those consequences are going to be
well for one probably the biggest thing
and
you know i i apologize for for not
focusing on the horror that's about to
engulf afghanistan but in strategic
terms the biggest thing is a complete
um undermining of u.s and western
reputations around the world which will
have consequences
um you know that we now see we and the
us and nato now seen as being fair with
our friends when the tough gets hard we
get the hell out of it and who's going
to rely on us and which which countries
that we're hoping to entice away from
china and russia
into the democratic sphere which of
those is going to be with us they're not
they're going to look more to russia and
china massive strategic consequences
china and russia are going to
do their best to to push the envelope
now knowing that you know where's the
where's the danger is america going to
strike back now probably not that's what
their calculation will be but then in in
you know other consequences we are we're
about to face the biggest terrorist
threat i think probably bigger than
before 911 with
um you know the taliban the new taliban
government announced a few days ago
is old guard hardline many of them on
wanted lists around the world including
un sanctions list
these these are not kind of people who
as they said are going to be looking for
equal opportunities and give you know
human rights and stuff they're not these
are hardline killers murders torturers
and rapists and they're running that
country and into that country is going
to flood jihadists from all around the
world so that that's a massive terrorist
problem for us and that that's even
before we begin to talk about what's
going to face men women and
children in afghanistan colonel look
there's going to be people who go look
we were in there 20 years you know tens
of thousands of people died we spent
almost two trillion dollars what more
could we want what more could we do
well i think we could understand the
situation a bit better than we did and
we didn't really understand it i don't
think we really got to grips with it we
didn't understand for example that most
afghans don't have
a kind of allegiance to afghanistan as a
country
you know they are tribal people that
their loyalty is to their tribe it's to
their ethnic group
it's to their local area that's where
the loyalty lies not to some concept
called afghanistan those people who
joined the army in afghanistan mostly
did so for the money they didn't join it
because they want to defend afghanistan
they did defend afghanistan very bravely
for many years 50 000 were killed over a
seven year period fighting for
afghanistan that is
two-thirds the size of the current
british army killed
in in seven years a massive thing but
that what they weren't fighting for
for for afghanistan they were fighting
for the money and the same really
applies to the government the the you
know the peripheral elements of the
government in the regions of afghanistan
in the provinces
didn't have loyalty to kabul that their
loyalty was really to their region to
themselves
and so when the kind of final guarantor
that they would survive under this kabul
regime
very very corrupt and incompetent regime
that they would survive in that regime
the final guarantor was the united
states of america when that pulled out
the whole edifice collapsed and we
didn't really understand that when we
were there colonel as a military man i
i'm not but i'm interested in history
military history can you explain to
people
and i know some of what you're about to
say but i think it's important how is it
possible that we've trained up a huge
army in afghanistan given them i mean
the taliban now have more gunship
helicopters than the uk apparently right
we've given all these weapons all the
training all the support and i
understand your point these people were
fighting for money and then the
guarantor disappeared but if we've
trained up a huge army given them modern
weapons gunships you know whatever else
apcs whatever else they got how is it
possible that they folded like this and
actually mostly without fighting as well
yeah there was very little fighting
during this this latest
phase of the war there was lots of
buying off
of different governors different you
know different military commanders etc
um but there wasn't much fighting and
and the rea you know in war um
the single most important factor is
morale napoleon i hate i really hate to
quote a frenchman but
hoping not to trigger any frenchmen
but um
napoleon said in war the moral is to the
physical as three is to one in other
words morale is three times as important
as all other factors
now the morale was a rug
a u.s with a u.s flag on it that the
americans whipped out from under their
feet therefore taking taking away
you know their their confidence their
their reason to stay fighting
um and the morale collapsed and then the
army collapsed and you know some of them
went over to the taliban
some of them
ran off to the panshir valley and
attempted to put up resistance there
which sadly looks like it's been for the
moment at least crushed
and some went back to their villages but
they you know i go back to this factory
about pay as well a lot of them hadn't
been paid for a long long time and and
you know if you if you're there
if you're fighting
um maybe under somebody under the
command of somebody who doesn't even
speak the same language as you from a
different part of afghanistan and you
know that the people that are supposed
to be paying you
put the money in their pocket instead
and you're rationed you're on half
rations because your commander is
selling the other half of the rations
now that doesn't you know those things
don't don't create a good level of
morale in the first place before this
carpet of morale is ripped out from
under your feet so
that makes perfect sense so let me ask
you the obvious question then if if we
spent 20 years and two trillion dollars
attempting to deal with that when were
we ever going to get in afghanistan to a
position where we could withdraw
well i'm not sure we would have done i
think it's it's a situation we could
have been in for a very long time you
know 20 years is not a long time it
certainly wasn't a long time for the
taliban they were very patient they held
out they fought on they eventually
scored a major victory for for us it is
a hell of a long time because we have
very little strategic patience but we
shouldn't forget we've been we had you
know there was british and american
forces in large numbers in germany until
very recently there still are a few
since the second world war
against a potential russian threat
predominantly for many years there was
you know the americans have still got
strong forces in south korea when the
korean war ended in the 50s
um we have troops in cyprus now serving
in cyprus with the united nations and
guarding our sovereign base areas
um my own regiment sir at the moment the
royal anglian regiment they they're
they're serving in in the british
sovereign base area in cyprus and that
is following a the turkish invasion of
cyprus which was a long time ago years
you know more than
20 years ago and we fought for pretty
much 40 years in northern ireland so you
know this is not a long time
we we i believe we needed to stay there
at least for longer than we did it
wasn't a huge commitment that i think
the lot the end of british combat
operations in afghanistan with 2014
and i don't think a british soldier has
been killed there since then or if they
have it's you know just one or two
and the same with americans very few
have been killed recently so we're not
talking about a hot conflict with lots
of people dying we're talking about
having
being there to provide the support
that a country that is coming out of the
most horrific situation needed and no
longer has so i think yeah i think we
should have been ready to stay for
another 20 years if need be but don't
you think the situation was ultimately
made unsustainable by the corruption by
the corruption in the afghan army by the
corruption in the government
well this is going to trigger a few
people into listening to this or
watching this and and that is that
uh
we needed to take a more imperial view
uh i i know the british empire was
terrible times and you know
very bad obviously it also did some good
around the world quite a lot of good but
that's not the broad view and i shall
now be canceled for saying this but
nevertheless that's what the show is
about ending your career ending your
career
but i think
well fortunately i no longer have a
career so you're fine i'm just messing
with you look i think sensible people
will hear what you say in the way that
you intended i i'd not really bothered
anymore good the reality is that the
united states should have
controlled the government more than it
did when i was there in 2003 whatever
the u.s ambassador said to president
karzai is what president karzai did
he didn't argue with it he didn't debate
it he just did it and the british
ambassador to a lesser extent had a
similar effect
they were running the country basically
uh with orders from washington and
london
but then they decided that the the the
government needed autonomy and
understandable in our terms that's
understandable but the result of that
autonomy was the collapse we've seen
today eventually you know massive
corruption many of the leaders
government leaders and officials in
afghanistan now have very large houses
and fortunes stashed away in dubai and
turkey and places like that
um
so they needed controlling and you know
a democracy which we tried to create
there perhaps wrongly but nevertheless
we tried cannot be created overnight it
takes a long time a lot of strong
guidance which we failed to give them in
my view and it isn't also the problem
that afghanistan as a country
it's just arbitrary lines on the map now
convert me if i'm wrong with you know
tribes who
are perpetually warring against each
other isn't it practically impossible to
turn that sort of state into a western
liberal democracy i think it is pretty
difficult as we've seen
you know and and to be fair i mean you
can't do something in 20 years if you
can do it at all and if that's what is
best for the people and what the people
in that country actually want
um then yeah you can try it but it's
more than a 20-year project
but but i would have thought you know
i'm not i'm not although i've been to
afghanistan i've followed what's
happened there i've taken part in
military operations i don't pretend to
be a afghan cultural expert but but what
i would say is that i think a better
idea might have been a much looser
federal kind of
arrangement that
is focused much more on the ethnic
groups and the provinces etc rather than
a duplicate of the us or a duplicate of
the uk with kabul as its capital and
what do you make a lot of people i've
spoken to a number of people who are
here in the uk who are from afghanistan
you know one of the things that they'll
say and look as a russian it's quite
easy for me to say you know
we keep interfering in all these foreign
countries and in their affairs and look
at al-qaeda al-qaeda is the product of
cia funding bin laden to fight the
soviets my people right and we keep
messing with these things and then
something happens and and al-qaeda beca
comes from that and then
the taliban came from the mujahideen to
some extent and we keep giving people
money that we don't really know and some
of them are terrorists and some of them
and we keep doing this and then it just
keeps coming back to bite us and us
because we keep messing with things we
don't really understand
i don't disagree with that and i think
but i do and you know i do think when
you look if you look at one of the
things you mentioned there the
the mujahideen fighting the russians
what we did there was the right thing to
do and that made up
your and your viewers but that created
bin laden who then right creates the
biggest terrorist attack
arguably yes but
but
um
the fact is that we were doing the right
thing in my view we were doing the right
thing we were we were pushing back
against the russians we were in the cold
war we were fighting the russians in the
cold war in so many different places
that was just one it was a very
important one
now you can't predict
what's going to happen as a result of
your actions in a situation like that i
don't think anyone no matter how clever
they were could have predicted that our
support for the mujahideen in
afghanistan would have led to the
situation we're in today similarly you
can say well we shouldn't really afford
this the first world war against the
germans expansionist policies in europe
because it led to the second world war
which it did but we didn't know that
wasn't known at the time it was you know
and you can say that about almost any
major event you you shouldn't have done
it in hindsight but it's not so easy
when you're making decisions at the same
time my point is slightly different
though and i i completely hear what you
say about the first world war and it
makes sense
my point is it's the type of people
we're dealing with
you're you're bringing the mujahid
mujahideen is not an afghan phenomenon
these were extremists from mostly from
saudi arabia brought in specifically
because they were extremists and we gave
them money and look this isn't me coming
at it from a russian angle by the way
i'm just i'm just trying to make the
point that i think when you deal with
these very bad people yeah
the consequences are going to be very
bad is that wrong absolutely that's
absolutely right and but but as a you
know i would say again you can't
foresee
you know unexpected unintended
consequences decades away you can only
to an extent you can only deal with the
situation as you face it although you
know maybe greater expertise will guide
you to do it in a different way
um but you know if you take the
consequences of you know the global war
on terror people say
for example people will say the london
suicide bomb attacks in 2005
um the 7 7 attacks
um they you know
sadiq khan who was the leader of those
attacks
said he was a soldier of islam he was
doing this because of what britain was
doing in muslim countries
but you know
the people then blame us for that but
but actually the the reason we were
doing what we were doing in muslim
countries was because we had suffered
911 right and you know and as i said
earlier we had to react to that in a
very forceful way
um
and then you know you it was at the
start of it no it wasn't really the side
of it so you keep looking back and back
i think you know i think there's a you
know there's there's
to look at things realistically you have
to
see see a situation as exist today
anticipate as much as you can the future
but deal with it or if you don't deal
with it you know people say well if we
hadn't gone
and into afghanistan or into iraq we
wouldn't have all these body bags coming
back true
and if we hadn't gone on to the beaches
of normandy in 1944 we wouldn't have all
the bodybuilders coming back from there
either but you you know you either do
nothing and let people run over you or
you make an attempt to to hit back at
them so i guess your argument which is
one i agree with is the soviet union had
to be defeated
at that time and we had to interfere on
that and the consequences are what the
consequences are but part of the
consequences are is that we no longer
have a hostile nuclear power
that is as big as the soviet union
challenging us right
that's very good way of putting i think
yeah yeah i would agree
and moving back towards afghanistan
it shocked so many people because it
literally seemed to happen overnight
could you give an explanation as to why
the us withdrawing in the manner that it
did was so disastrous
well
i think the first thing is that that
president
biden made the decision in april that he
was going to go
he did so um
he was given options by his team that
reviewed the situation in afghanistan
when he became president
or when he was elected president and um
he he was given a series of options one
of which was what he did but it wasn't
the one he had to do it was only one of
the options he had
um and then he immediately announced it
and it was to happen in very short order
you know the the
the british
foreign minister for foreign secretary
in evidence he gave to parliament not
long ago he himself said that even in
britain people didn't really believe the
americans were going to do it
you know they would they announced it
and they they said they intended to but
we didn't believe it really was going to
happen it was hard to comprehend
which accounted for our
i think misappreciation of the situation
as well but if you can imagine a british
government taking every what's the
afghan government going to view they're
going to take they they would just they
disbelieved it they did not expect it to
happen they couldn't they couldn't
really face it because they knew what
the consequences were likely to be
so they they were they were told that
they weren't even given time to adjust
to the idea
that it was going to happen and then to
plan
for a new situation now whether they
could have planned and organized
themselves and organized the army in
such a way that something different
would have happened i don't know but
they weren't given that chance it was a
very short flash to bang period and then
as i mentioned before
the the withdrawal took place in august
um not in which was at the height of the
power of the taliban it's their fighting
season it's when they're most active
it's when they're all on the ground
trying to kill people and i'm just going
to interrupt you the fighting season
what does that mean well it's they tend
to fight they tend to be more active in
fighting
in the in the summer months okay unless
in the winter months you talk about them
like there's some kind of termite or
something that comes out of its burrow
isn't it that is the reality
i mean you know
and it's understandable in a way because
it's true in different many parts of the
world people do tend to kind of
wind back in during the
the more harsh periods of the year the
winter and that's what the taliban did
you know traditionally well most of the
fighting by the british forces american
forces in afghanistan was done you know
over the sort of late spring
summer early autumn type period and the
rest of the year there was less it was
less active so if he'd waited let's say
until
um
i don't know until the late autumn of
winter then it's likely that wouldn't we
would not have seen such a rapid and
immediate collapse of the go over the
government and its forces there
and the other you know the other the
other problem i think
of this situation the other reason is
catastrophe is because
for some reason
biden withdrew all the us forces pretty
much most of them before evacuating the
civilian population
the civilian population should have been
evacuated from the time he made his
decision back in april over months and
we wouldn't have seen this fiasco and
it's the same with the british we should
have started it back then when they made
the decision originally to withdraw we
would not have seen this utter disaster
which is so damaging it's obviously you
know cost a lot of lives there's lots of
hostages in afghanistan now who wouldn't
be there if they've been evacuated and
it was so damaging to the reputation of
the image of of the west so you know i
think that
all of those different factors had they
been
done in a different way and contrary to
what we're talking about foreseeing the
future all of this you know a second
left tenant when he first received his
training at sandhurst or at west point
in america
would have been trained to avoid all
these situations so why didn't they
if it's basic training why didn't they
why won't they do that i don't know i
don't know but i think there will be an
investigation
and you know and i think there should be
an independent inquiry into what
happened both in britain and in america
and other countries and in nato um
not not to have a witch hunt and nail
people to the
to a stake or something but to um
to learn the lessons from it and find
out what really did happen to make sure
nothing like it happens again if we have
any similar type of situation but like i
just can't answer it it's so illogical
i've spoken to many sort of experienced
military people who just really can't
understand the thinking behind what
happened there
we do have heard that the the
intelligence
community as it's now called did suggest
that the afghan army wouldn't be able to
hold off
so
it's it's kind of odd that it's happened
that way the information apparently was
available
i think i think there was you know we
people saw people saw the options
that you know i think you know the
possibilities that it might be that they
couldn't
you know hold hold the thing together
for very long or they would lose the
plot immediately or whatever it might
take a lot longer there were different
options i don't think anyone came not
that i've seen anyone came to that
specific i think the u.s intelligence
assessment
and the british intelligence assessment
i'm not saying there weren't dissenting
views
was that the government would hold up
until the end of the year okay that was
there that was the best assessment but
a military person knows you should never
plan for the best case you should plan
always for the worst almost dangerous
case and very clearly that's not what
happened yeah and i wanted to ask you
because obviously a lot has been made
and you know not wrongly so of the
amount of equipment and arms and and the
money that was essentially left to now
the taliban do you think that could have
been avoided or did did we have to leave
that equipment to the afghan army so
that they would in our minds at least
have the chance to defend themselves is
that what's happened or has this been a
catastrophic mistake of just handing
weapons and material to the enemy i
think as we didn't appreciate the speed
at which the afghan forces would
collapse and we we didn't you know the
the us the uk didn't appreciate that
um
they couldn't just have taken all the
weapons away when they went i don't
think you know
or before before or during the taliban
offensive you couldn't have done that
would be even worse than what we did
um but i think now
uh
now is the time to try and deal with it
to to destroy some of it if we can and
you know we can we can work out the
concentrations of the equipment and
strike it from the air i don't think we
will do that because we've got hostages
in the country partly because because
there are hostages in the country but
also because we
um we seem to be more interesting in
trying to negotiate with the taliban
and become on good terms somehow with
the taliban which i think is a mistake
but i can unders i can understand why
um we should
not not destroy this kit but you know
it's an option that could be taken i
think in the circumstances it's not
going to happen sorry i interrupted you
there but i'm very curious because i
instinctively it doesn't make sense to
me why we're negotiating with the
taliban given how you've described them
given the people that they're now
putting in power
basically terrorists that we've we've
been looking for for decades
but
to to people listening to this who maybe
take a neutral view or don't know what
to think why is there a mistake to
negotiate with the taliban well
i i mean the i think i think one of the
i'll give two sort of answers to that on
the first the first point really um
why why are we wanting to negotiate why
are we wanting to kind of negotiate with
them and be on good terms of them
and and i think the answer to that lies
in um
in president biden's reputation
or lack of at the moment
he was talking about how almost and and
other members of the us administration
as well
talking about how
uh we're kind of on the same side now
against the islamic state
who he described in a recent speech as
the sworn enemies of the taliban
and and and there's been talk of for
example british british forces
helping to train
the taliban to deal with the islamic
state they're just an extraordinary
well i hope not but that's bit there's
been consideration of that and some
members of parliament have been
sort of advancing the idea as well are
these people mental well in my view yes
but but not in their own view but the
going back to the point about um
about being friends with the taliban i
think president biden i mean by the way
the taliban and al-qaeda the taliban and
the islamic state are not sworn enemies
none of them are they're jihadists they
have the same agenda they have the same
doctrine they have the same intentions
they just wear different cat badges
sometimes they hate each other and kill
each other sometimes they're friendly
with each other that's the way it works
in that part of the world you know we
don't we can't really comprehend it
because it's not our culture but it is
their culture and we should be able to
comprehend it um but but it was much
better for president biden now to to
advance the the narrative that
we've we've basically handed over
afghanistan to these guys who are going
to be helping us fight the islamic state
which is the greatest season that's that
agenda the reason we shouldn't they
aren't the other part of the answer the
reason we shouldn't um
negotiate with the taliban i think will
be in good terms of the taliban
the the taliban's victory which is the
greatest victory for islamic jihadists i
think in modern times
um even greater for example than the the
uh the overtaking of of iran by
um the ayatollahs back in 1979 which
created a terrorist state in iran we now
also have a terrorist state a sunni
terror state as opposed to a shia terror
state in uh in afghanistan
that victory is is hugely damaging to
the west and hugely
inspirational
to
insurgency movements
and jihadists everywhere it's it's the
greatest inspiration they would have had
certainly in my memory
defeating the great satan the west the
us nato they've defeated it and it's got
a it can only be something that will
celebrate they will celebrate they have
been inspiring and inspire you know
insurgents in many different places
around the world to to overtake the
country that they're fighting against um
so
that's already there but recognizing
them
which effectively amounts to kind of
bowing to them
showing them deference um
it's just going to add to that it's
going to give them greater credibility
than they have now and it's not going to
achieve anything because none of these
people are going to be influenced by
what we say we talk you know i think
nancy pelosi in the u.s said um
she said um
you know the taliban must have
uh you know women in the government
i mean you know
the government is made up of terrorists
perhaps should like women terrorists in
the government as well i don't know
that's progressive isn't it that is
progressive but that's that's the kind
of stuff that's coming out and but
anyway they're not going to they haven't
taken those so because there are no
women they're not only terrorist women
in their government so they don't take
notes of what she says they don't take
notice what we say they won't do either
they'll do what they want to do china
will be the players in afghanistan now
they will be and pakistan of course but
china and pakistan will be the major
influences in in afghanistan from now
not britain not america
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
and so what do you think the future
holds for afghanistan
i think um
i think there'll be now a period of
relative peace
the the the panchiris the nor the the
kind of
the the renewal of what was the northern
alliance which fought against the
taliban during its previous reign in
afghanistan and managed to prevent it
from taking the north of the country
um
the panshiris
have pretty much been i think crushed by
the taliban according to some rumors and
i don't know this there are any rumors
with assistance from pakistan from
pakistan military which is beyond beyond
possible because the pakistan military
basically created the taliban and
enabled the taliban to to achieve what
it's achieved today um but with them out
of the way
maybe maybe they'll re
uh generate themselves hopefully and and
become a thorn in the flesh for the
taliban i hope they do
um
but at any rate there will be i would i
would uh anticipate to be a period of
relative peace for maybe a year two
years
because you know the the the country's
been at war for a long time people want
they actually do even with the taliban
they want
a degree of stability and relative lack
of violence they won't get it under the
taliban but that's what they want um and
then i think we'll see maybe in a couple
of years time or maybe even less
an upright one or more uprisings against
the taliban in the country and we'll see
some kind of maybe civil war is going a
bit too far but certainly some kind of
um resistance against the taliban
happening
um and meanwhile we will see a very
repressed repressive government people
already journalists being whipped
for reporting on you know demonstrations
taking place in different cities people
being executed taliban going to door
looking for people who were working for
the british working for the americans
who worked for the last government who
were doing human rights work anything
like that
going around rounding them up dealing
with them
we will see you know women not allowed
out of their houses without the male
escort without being covered head to
foot girls and women not really being
educated the you know they say oh they
can be educated in
in accordance with sharia law we know
what that means
so that that's that's going to be the
country and it'll it'll probably get
uh economic support from some form of
economic support from china in return
for allowing china to plunder its
resources and in return for as much
stability as the taliban can impose
and when you see everything that has
happened and you served in the military
and you i imagine have had friends who
have lost their lives
does it make you feel that those
servicemen have lost their lives in vain
for nothing no it doesn't far from it um
i think um i mean what we shouldn't
forget is the reason we went to
afghanistan we went there in 2001
in relatively small numbers with the us
in also relatively small numbers and
together with this northern alliance
that i mentioned
defeated the taliban and al-qaeda and
then there was the resurgence
but we went there to get rid of the
taliban and al qaeda particularly
al-qaeda who carried out 911 that was
the reason it was counter terrorism
mission
um to make sure it didn't happen again
we stayed and you know we discussed
before whether it's right or wrong to
say we did stay and we stayed for one
reason we stayed to
prevent
afghanistan from again becoming a safe
haven for terrorists from which they
could attack the west
we achieved that mission
uh and and the british soldiers and
american soldiers and other soldiers who
were killed there died
protecting british citizens who would
otherwise have died by terrorist attack
launched from afghanistan and citizens
of allied countries so that was it was
it was a success
in that respect in the terms of the pure
mission it was a um
it was a sacrifice that was necessary
and worth making and i say that knowing
many soldiers who have been killed there
and the families of many so we should be
killed so i'm not saying it lightly but
i do not believe that their sacrifice
was in vain people talk about different
missions when we were in afghanistan you
know for the whole period the mission
has changed and shifted and is it to
counter narcotics is it to give women's
rights is it to they enable girls to go
to school no it was none of those things
it wasn't any yes of course all those
advantages if you can achieve them but
the mission was to destroy terrorism not
to um to put women on equal footing with
men in afghanistan desirable there that
might be
now
moving on
that that sacrifice that was made and
that success and that effectively
effectively that victory which i would
call it against terrorism has now been
betrayed by this withdrawal because that
threat remains there it's not gone away
president biden says
the war is now over i have ended the war
in afghanistan no he hasn't he's pulled
the american troops out he's betrayed
those troops that fought there for 20
years he's betrayed his own countrymen
who are now at greater threat from
terrorism than before 911 and he's
betrayed the people of afghanistan
although there are plenty of other
people in the world we could fight for
who need us to fight for but we don't
have the resources to fight for
everybody and we weren't actually
fighting for the people in afghanistan
we were fighting for our people's safety
and you talk about terrorism and you
referred earlier to the fact that these
people are all jihadis the taliban al
qaeda isis etc and you talked about they
have the same vision we've had a number
of people on the show former al-qaeda
members turned double agents and other
people who've studied the region very
well
what is your understanding of these
people's agenda what do they want
well
essentially they want a global islamic
caliphate
they want
first of all
they want all countries in the world
that were ever under islamic rule
to return to islamic rule
and that includes spain for example
where which was originally part of the
caliphate includes of course israel
um and and you know a number of other
places that were once under islamic
dispensation
and not only that
it wants them under their
idea of islam not for example
jordan's idea of islam or the uae's idea
of islam but
the fundamentalist idea of islam
closer to what saudi arabia is but saudi
arabia of course is also not seen as
legitimate islam for a number of reasons
partly because it is also allied to the
united states that can't be so that's
the first stage and the second stage is
then to
engulf the rest of the world that wasn't
ever islam but it's a duty to take back
those lands that were once islamic lands
and then to extend that to the rest of
the world but but they don't people like
al qaeda and bin laden
and and also i would guess the taliban
and islamic state don't see that as
something they're going to achieve
what they see they see that in the long
long distant future
they see
creating steps towards that process as
being their mission in other words
to kill as many people as possible as
many um non-muslims as possible and as
many apostate muslims as possible
and to set muslims against non-muslims
in other words to creating country up
this civil war between muslims and
non-muslims that's their their their
kind of way of eventually working
towards this process and that's their
object that's all of their objectives in
different in you know in different ways
the taliban before 9 11 were focused
mainly they weren't so much focused on
that wider objective they were focused
more on afghanistan that was their place
that was what they wanted they wanted to
run it they wanted it to be the way they
wanted it
now
20 years later they've been they've
spent 20 years fighting the west they've
got many new members in the in the
organization who are more outwardly
focused some of them have been to
guantanamo bay as guests of the
americans there and so they
they've now changed their perspective to
an extent and at least some of them also
have that outward focus of of conquering
the world and in some of the recent
statements they've made that's come
through
and i guess people here in the west i
think
there's so many so many things we don't
understand about how the rest of the
world works i mean you talk about the
decline of america and nato's reputation
and that was the first thing that
obviously stuck out to me as someone
coming from russia most people in the
rest of the world understand only one
language which is strength right
strength and force right if you're
stronger they will listen to the words
that you say if you and nancy pelosi
they weren't because they know there's
nothing behind that right
but the other thing we don't understand
is the power of conviction
and the power of belief and these people
are ideological right that they have an
ideology that drives them forward
because a lot of people might in the
west look at the town and go look
they've got their country quote-unquote
back they've got control they've got
american weapons they've got money
they're now negotiating with the west
why why would they want to attack us
like why would they want to you know you
talk about there's going to be more
threat of terrorism than before 9 11.
surely they just they're just going to
go back to being nice peaceful afghans
and living in prosperity
yeah unfortunately the
very few people do actually understand
um
cultures foreign to their own
they they you know there's there's a
modern trend of wanting to claim that
all cultures are equal
and therefore worthy of respect
um but really without any attempt to
understand them they're just they're
they're probably better than us
but we don't really need to understand
them and they don't understand them
and that's why you get
um you know
staunch feminists who complain
about some builder whistling at a woman
walking down the street which might well
be offensive i don't know i've never
experienced it don't ever expect to but
but that's their complaint the complaint
is not that women get stoned to death in
countries like afghanistan that women
get are forced to wear
robes that cover them head to foot
that's not their complaint that because
it's a culture that's superior to ours
probably they don't understand it and
they then they also make a pretense that
women do it voluntarily which they
really don't in any of these countries
who would who could possibly um
you know
there's kind of a it's in many ways it's
kind of a um
a british not it's not and it's not any
british but a a british ignorance and
arrogance that um
that really allows this misunderstanding
to to go on and i think it you know it's
i i i was i had a knife at my throat
from an afghan
at the age of 17 in england
um for a cultural misunderstanding
i don't think i was particularly to
blame although he did and he blamed the
entire history and betrayal of his race
on me for that for that uh one thing but
you know since then since 17 when i
first encountered a very very different
culture i've i've done my best to learn
from it and to and to appreciate and
understand it but not
necessarily to respect it
i guess the question
uh
a lot of people would probably want to
understand is
why
why would these people continue to
engage in terrorism now they've won
right they've got money they've got
gunships they've got weapons they've got
their country under their control
what
they are about to be negotiated with by
the the western powers
why why would they continue to try and
kill innocent people why why continue
terrorist attacks why are you concerned
about that
well
because because it's it's basically in
their in their religious doctrine you
mentioned just now they have they're
kind of zealous people they have they
have you know doctrinal inspiration
um they're ideological and it's in their
ideology they have to do it it's it's
what they're told they have to do
um
if even let's say even if some or the
majority of the taliban
leadership are not focused externally
which i i don't really think is the case
now but let's say that's the case they
are so closely linked and aligned to al
qaeda in particular and have been for
many many years and have fought
alongside al qaeda
for 20 years against the west including
the the you know in the in the fighting
in august
they they owe something to al-qaeda so
they owe them to operate out of
afghanistan they don't owe anything to
you or me not to kill not to let
al-qaeda kill our
sister or daughter or anything like that
or wife they they
they they owe something to al-qaeda and
therefore they will
they you know they will pay their chips
to al-qaeda and al-qaeda will carry on
attacking from the same with the islamic
state they're not as closely linked but
nevertheless they're all on the same
side they pretty much want the same sort
of thing
it's a very very bleak picture that
you're painting there do you think part
of the problem in the west is that we've
forgotten what it means to go to war
we're so disconnected in this country in
america from the idea of going to war
from the idea of battle from the idea of
fighting
none of us really know apart from
yourselves but
everybody else of my generation has
never been to war has never been to
fight
i think it's a very good point and
there's a
you know if you if you look at
many of the statements made in
parliament
with the exception of certainly some of
the maybe all of the former military mps
that are there now and there are a few
now more than there were but if you um
if you look at a lot of things said
there it cl it clearly betrays
a lack of understanding of of war um and
this is people who are supposed to be
directing war like the prime minister
the foreign secretary maybe not the
defense secretary who was in the army
himself um
but but they you know that i think that
their kind of lack of urgency
has
has betrayed their lack of understanding
of war and you know for example
the foreign secretary
as he was has been discussed endlessly
in the media was on holiday when all
this started now to me that if i'd been
on holiday when when this started i'd
have been straight back
because this is a situation that
requires leadership grip and commands
and he was the man to do that but he
didn't i would say he was kind of
thinking this is another crisis the
foreign office deals with lots of
different crises and i don't come back
from holiday every time i think that
kind of thing shows a
lack of of understanding of war i think
i think many people in this country
they they only most vast majority of
people of course in this country
thankfully only understand war from what
they see on their television or in their
computer game which isn't probably that
close to reality
but
i think many of them do
um certainly many of the people i've
spoken to do understand
that you know not if not understand it
they they support certainly support the
soldiers even if they don't support
necessarily the political aims behind
their military operations and i thought
i think that's improved over my the time
since i first joined the army it's
improved a great deal when we were doing
a lot of
very dangerous and difficult demanding
operations in northern ireland and no
one
really knew or cared anything about it
very much whereas i think
the afghanistan and iraq campaign saw a
great deal more public support and
that's probably because of the media i
think more than anything else i'm going
to ask you a question and it's an a very
layman-like question but i'm sure that a
lot of people will want it answered what
does it mean to go to war as a soldier
what does that mean to be
flown into somewhere like afghanistan in
a place where you know you have no
connection you've never been before you
don't know the language and then be
plunged into conflict
well it's probably the most exciting
thing you'll ever do in your life
and and it's it's you know i i'm
speaking as somebody who volunteered to
join the army
um
and and everyone in the british army
today also volunteered to join the arm
we don't have any conscripts anymore
and if you volunteer to join the army
you did so because you want to fight
and that sounds shocking you want to
fight
you don't want people to be at war you
don't want
civilians to get killed or whatever you
don't want to see your mate getting
killed but you don't if you don't want
to fight you don't join the army
um and it's i always kind of liken it to
a surgeon
a surgeon doesn't want to see a traffic
accident with people maimed and mangled
and mauled
but he wants to be the one that chops
the leg off if it needs amputating
that's what he's trained to do it's what
he gets satisfaction from doing a good
job repairing the person as best he can
so he can have as good a life as
possible and a soldier is the same a
soldier i think wants to fight wants the
excitement of combat
um
you know there is huge there are huge
problems with it as well don't get me
wrong everything is not you know as it
is maybe in a movie there are some
terrible part aspects to it but
i i you know i've known many soldiers
myself included who who really live
to go from military operation to
military operation and the stuff in
between is just pretty boring now i
appreciate i don't speak for everybody
and there are many people who are
terribly badly scarred by war both
physically and mentally who wouldn't
want to go near another one again once
they've done it but i think you know
really i go back to the thing i may say
before if you don't want to fight why
would you why would you possibly join
the army
we talk about ethics and we talk about
the geneva convention war crimes etc etc
and we talked about marine b before the
interview would you be able to talk
about that particular case and why you
disagreed with the way that that soldier
was treated
yeah i think you you um
ethics and and the rules of war and the
laws of war are extremely important
uh and i think it you know i think
you know there may be some soldiers who
who would have no qualms
other than to um to to kill people as
and when they could without if they
don't really need to i've never met one
myself i'm sure not say there aren't any
but i would i think any government or
any military commander would find it
extremely hard to ask a soldier
to fight without
ethics without you know without adhering
to the laws of war i think it's
extremely important
if you if you do that if you if you try
and get people to do things that are
outside those those laws then you're
you're really condemning them not just a
potential criminal activity but also to
you know to
real moral hazard for themselves which
could affect them in untold ways so i
think it's really important um
marine a who
who was
accused and convicted for murder
for killing a wounded
taliban soldier in
afghanistan
i never believed he should have been
convicted for murder
um
and ultimately his his on appeal his
conviction was overturned and he was not
any longer convicted of murder and he
was released from prison but he did
serve a period of time in prison what he
did was wrong it was against the geneva
convention it was against the laws of
war it's immoral it was unnecessary and
it was completely wrong could you just
explain what he actually did right he he
shot
a there was a wounded taliban prisoner
who
um was probably about to die he was so
severely wounded he probably would not
have survived
and he shot him
got to get rid of him to finish him off
yeah basically
and um
that he should not have done because
that is murder even in a war situation
at his murder what he should have done
was to do his best to patch him up and
then evacuate him if he could to
somewhere he could get better treatment
maybe he would die on the way but that
wouldn't have been that would have been
the right thing to do but he didn't
and it was filmed one of his fellow
soldiers filmed this happening and so it
was
it was you know there wasn't any dispute
as to the facts of what happened but my
opinion is that the reason he shouldn't
have and this is the reason he was
eventually
his conviction was overturned on appeal
was that he was
suffering
from the most extreme stress which
caused him to behave
in
a very uncharacteristic way and in an
illegal way but stress sometimes does
that to people battle stress he'd been
on numerous operational tours he'd seen
some unspeakable things done
to his fellow marines
um and and he was he was behaving out
really outside of his control he was he
was really not mentally capable of doing
what he was doing
um
and that was the eventual finding of the
court of appeal
um and and and i think you know
for whatever reason his first court
martial
um
kind of treated him
as if he'd been
someone in south london stabbing
a rival to get drug money or something
like that and it's not like that at all
it's a totally you know it has to be
looked as a totally different situation
he was not acting
in my view he was not acting in you know
under his own
mental control um
and and you and you do get that i
mentioned earlier that the levels of
stress
um
and the the horrors that people see and
experience can have very very bad
effects on their minds but doesn't that
also go back to my point of people you
know and there may be very educated
people in the law in pol they don't
understand what it's like
you know i remember talking to my
grandfather who who fought in el alamein
and he fought in in the second world war
and he fought in italy and he said you
only really see the soldiers when the
lead's flying yeah and he goes and you
will never know what that's like so for
us to therefore judge him is ridiculous
because we don't know what it's like
well i certainly don't to have an
islamic fundamentalist with an ak-47
trying to blow my head off
i agree and it's it's it's a
it it is very difficult to understand
unless you've actually experienced
something like that but in fact in the
case of mourinho we were talking about
the people judging him were soldiers
because there's a military court martial
so they should have i i believe they
should have done it differently i mean
you know i've sat on court martials
myself and different factors come into
play
i i don't i'm not accusing them of um
of being corrupted
um but
i do believe it suited the army
it suited the government for for
mourinho to be convicted now i i i'm not
sure how that was
how that kind of desire from the
armed forces and from the government was
transmitted into a conviction in a court
martial but i know it certainly did suit
them i guess what the point france was
making was more about the commentary and
the media because i remember seeing that
story at the time as someone who's not
in any way involved in the military it
just seemed like a bunch of people in
comfortable armchairs in in westminster
talking about somebody who was in in a
combat situation and look
as you say the geneva convention and the
laws of war and all of that exist but to
expect someone who's just been shot at
and nearly killed having served and seen
horrible things to to immediately treat
uh someone who's about to die anyway as
it's
i i see both sides of it but i don't
think it's reasonable to just expect
them to to behave with utmost moral
perfection in that situation and you
can't be you can't be clinical in my
view um and and you know in all wars
throughout history leeway has been shown
to soldiers who have transgressed the
laws of war
you know
there's a real difference between
somebody who
um in the heat of battle
because they're wound up there you know
they've seen lots of people killed
around them they're they're they're you
know they're they're really aggressive
and with you know blood dripping from
them really in in a very tough combat
situation
um
you've got to treat people differently
in that situation from let's say
an ss squad that lines a group of
soldiers up against the wall and machine
guns them and murders them which
happened to a company from my own
regiment in the second world war just
before the dunkirk evacuation so you
know
you know war there's war crimes
and there are soldiers behaving in a way
that
you know you can't control human beings
like automatons in some circumstances
and i think that definitely needs to be
understood but we're seeing we've seen
um
far too many
cases of soldiers being prosecuted and
investigated endlessly investigated as a
result of allegations made against them
in iraq in afghanistan and in northern
ireland and today we're watching as as
sort of old age pensioners who were once
soldiers who are being hounded through
the courts in northern ireland
for alleged offences they committed half
a century ago
half a century ago
and you know th this is
this is being done for political
objectives all of it is being done for
political protectives in the case of the
northern ireland
um allegations that are being ha which
soldiers being hounded there it is
essentially an attempt by
irish republicans to rewrite history
to present their terrorists as the good
guys and british soldiers
as the war criminals which is the dead
the total reverse of the truth
in afghanistan it was
and iraq the allegations were made for a
rather different reason but it was it
was one was money
and the other one was um
iraqis and afghans in some cases were
making allegations and encouraged to do
so by british laws in order to score
political points over over over you know
british and western governments
well nice to end on a non-controversial
note there uh colonel it's been an
absolute pleasure we're going to ask you
a couple of questions for our local
supporters before in a second but before
we do we've got one final question for
you as always which is always what's the
one thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
i think i think in this context about
there are many things in the world we're
not talking about i think in the context
of our conversation one of the biggest
problems we face at the moment
is is
um
two things one one is um radicalization
and de-radicalization
and you know we've seen cases recently
in the last couple of years in london
where
islamic terrorists who have been
convicted done their sentence been led
out of prison have gone through radical
deradicalization programs have then
carried out attacks which goes to show
our de-radicalization programs
do not work clearly certainly not in
those cases i suspect and you know many
people who are closer involved than i am
in prisons etc have confirmed that um
that our de-radicalization programs
leave a lot to be desired so you know
because because if people are
indoctrinated they have they have a
religious belief in their mind
it's it's not like it's not the same as
a common criminal who can be
made to understand and deterred from
carrying out his crime by punishment
sometimes
religious beliefs and indoctrination
transcends
punishment and i think in many of the
cases of jihadists it does so
if we're not to keep them in prison
indefinitely which obviously is highly
undesirable in any democratic society
then we need to do more about we need to
talk more about de-radicalization and i
would argue we need to try and involve
countries like the uae
and other other countries in the middle
east which are muslim countries to be
involved in our de-radicalization
programs and the second thing that
people aren't talking about you're
getting two for the price of one is the
same is linked to the same kind of
problem which is how you deal how you
deal with prisoners
of this conflict it's a multi is it's a
sort of multi-generational conflict
that we're facing this is not going to
end
in five years 10 years or 50 years it's
going to go on for a very long time this
this jihadist conflict um
and how do you deal with with people you
capture
the it goes back to the radicalization
point but if you look at guantanamo bay
you know president obama vowed to end
guantanamo bay he did two terms in
office it's still there now because
there was no solution in a conventional
war
you capture prisoners and when the war
is over you release those prisoners
because hostilities are finished this is
not going to finish
so there will never come a time when
you can really release and expect them
no longer to be fighting you and we've
seen you know we've got in afghanistan
today in the government in certainly in
among the taliban leadership people have
been to guantanamo bay so they you know
they were released and they're still
fighting so it's it's it's a real
problem i don't have the answers but i
think one of your extremely clever
listeners probably ought to come up with
the answer to that question let me
follow up very briefly because
guantanamo bay
it it
i don't know it just grinds so much
against my liberal instincts what
happened there do you think it was a
mistake or do you think it was necessary
and do you think we're gonna have to do
more of that i think
unless someone comes up with a better
solution
it was a necessary evil
um and i don't i don't really understand
um
how you can deal with a problem like
islamic jihadism
which is a conflict not a [ __ ] this is
not criminal activity it is a criminal
in act but it's much more like a
conflict
how you can deal with it without some
something like guantanamo bay and you
know even the genius
president obama a law professor elected
twice to the uh you know the most
powerful man in the world twice he
couldn't figure out a solution to it so
if he couldn't i certainly i'm not going
to be able to what about all the
waterboarding and all that stuff surely
that was unnecessary yeah i think i
think i think it was um you know
torture is a very controv if you just
call it torture i guess it we would
certainly classify it as torture is a
very controversial thing
um
and it's you know certainly forbidden
under our under our laws and i don't
think i you know i would not support it
i was never involved in anyone and i
would not support it but having said
that i can understand in some
circumstances why people why why they
did it in in those
in that situation and the reason they
did it was because they were so fearful
of another 9 11.
now that doesn't excuse what happened
but i think it sort of explains
why they felt that such extreme measures
needed to be taken
and it wasn't just not about you know
another 911 flying aircraft into
building it was the knowledge and the
intelligence that suggested that
um
you know that these jihadists were
trying to get their hands on
biological weapons chemical weapons and
nuclear weapons and getting close
towards it in some circumstances so
you know it's a it's it's not a not an
excuse but i think an explanation this
someone should have told them they just
need to get a bat to sneeze on them if
they needed a biological weapon uh we've
ended up with one
no further than wuhan exactly color
richard kemp it's been an absolute
pleasure where can people find your work
your writing etc online how do they how
to find out more about what's going on
i've got a website which is called
richard heifenkemp.com
and i'm on twitter which is at
col richard kemp so if you want to abuse
me for any of the
horrible cancelable
triggerable uh comments i've made then
you can get me on those things i've got
plenty of reviews already so please join
in
colonel it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much and if you've enjoyed
this interview and you want to see
others we they always go out wednesday
sunday 7 p.m uk time 2 p.m eastern
standard oral raw which always go out at
the very same time take care and see you
soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below